[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans cette
édition du 7 8 journal sur tv 78 nous
sommes le mardi 10 juillet tout de suite
les titres en un an près de 1000 offres
d'emploi disponibles dans ce secteur à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'agglomération misent sur le numérique
est dès la rentrée 13 formation école du
numérique seront accessible après le bac
une réunion d'information et de
présentation se tenait hier après-midi
attrape les yvelinois se préparent ils
seront près ce soir à 20 heures devant
leur télévision la france affronte la
belgique pour une place en finale de la
coupe du monde de football une rencontre
à suivre sur écran géant dans plusieurs
communes saint-quentinoise mais aussi
dans les nombreux bars du territoire
enfin en juillet et en août les villes
du département passe en mode était elle
propose des activités notamment pour les
jeunes exemple dans ce journal à
montigny le bretonneux avec était en
sable est mais aussi à guyancourt nous
en parlons avec notre invité et des
formations labellisées école du
numérique dès la rentrée à saint quentin
en yvelines pour mieux les connaître une
réunion était organisée hier après-midi
à trappes est développeur web ou encore
réseaux et sécurité le public a pu
découvrir 13 formations disponibles à
partir du niveau bac l le point avec
aurélie rosé car la vision devenir
analyste en cybersécurité ou assistant
de sécurisation de données
dès la rentrée treize formation
labellisée école du numérique seront
disponibles sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
en tout 300 futurs talents s'apprête à
être formés
c'est les emplois de demain vous savez
bien et puis les entreprises nous ont
fait part de leurs besoins et on
souhaité venir d organiser formation qui
n'était pas saint quentin en yvelines
pour qu'elles proposent des formations
qui correspondent aux besoins des
entreprises cet organisme ont présenté
leur formation comme o'clock
il propose de vous apprendre les bases
du métier de développeur web tout en
restant chez vous on est à distance chez
soi la plupart du temps à domicile mais
en interaction permanente avec un
formateur qui est en direct vidéo avec
qui on échange comme comme s'il était à
côté on l'entend il nous entend on peut
lui parler et en interaction permanente
aussi avec les autres stagiaires de la
formation commence tous les jours à 9
heures jusqu'à midi après une pause pour
déjeuner à 13 euros prend jusqu'à 15
heures
la plupart de ces formations est
accessible sans diplôme particulier et
s'adresse donc un large public
j'ai un petit job hors intérimaires et
cette année j'ai envie de me reconvertir
dans le numérique
je trouvais ce que cherche à au moins
trois formations qui m'intéresse
beaucoup
le numérique un secteur d'avenir à saint
quentin en yvelines qui a recensé en un
an dix mille offres d'emploi et ce soir
d'ailleurs le dernier numéro de mode
d'emploi sera consacré aux métiers du
numérique et de la cyber sécurité une
émission présentée bien sûr par or il
est onze elle vous étiez près de 13
millions de téléspectateurs pour la
dernière victoire des bleus à la coupe
du monde de football ce soir l'équipe de
france joue sa place en finale du
mondial en russie pour ce faire il
faudra battre nos amis et voisins de la
belgique et les yvelinois se prépare
d'ici le coup d'envoi à 20h et des
retransmissions sur écran géant sont au
programme à elancourt plaisir villepreux
ou encore bois d'arcy lé bar de saint
quentin en yvelines vont aussi faire le
plein bonsoir miquel et demi d'euros
vous êtes depuis le bistrot du théâtre à
montigny le bretonneux et l'ambiance
monte petit à petit michael oui
effectivement grégory l'ambiance monte
petit à petit l'effervescence même ici
ça s'annonce volcanique tout simplement
je suis au bistrot du théâtre est à mes
côtés
le responsable gilles gilles est ce que
vous attendez beaucoup de monde ce soir
on voit qui a déjà beaucoup de monde
comme dit zizou ça va être un truc de
ouf un truc de fou
fousseret de monde partout on attend
quelques centaines de personnes et je ne
me vois là je rigole pas c'est vraiment
ça va tout le monde est prêt toute
l'équipe est à bloc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
problème quand les retiennent et il ya
encore autant au piano là derrière ça ma
peau cyr donc 500 personnes sur répartis
sur cinq écrans je crois oui c'est à peu
près ça oui au moins aux cinq et trente
trois ou quatre dehors de l'intérieur
trois dehors de l'intérieur est-ce que
ça va être une ambiance volcanique
vraiment une ambiance historique qu'on
n'aura jamais vu ici
et bien sûr il faut c'est une guerre
fratricide on va dire un contre nos amis
les belges on va essayer de les battre
mais ils vont essayer de nous le rendre
donc voilà mais bon nous sommes très
confiants
qui va gagner ce soir l'équipe l'a alors
je suis aussi avec des supporters ayoub
ayoub vous avez sorti la perruque est
aujourd'hui exactement oui jusqu'au bout
il va falloir qu'ils gagnent ce soir
vous nous faire un beau match je pense
et on sera fier d'eux je pense à la fin
de ce match historique
alors je crois savoir que vous avez
parié gros seins ce soir sur l'équipe de
france
j'ai confiance en mon équipe je pense
qu'ils vont gagner oui j'ai parié à
montant 250 euros pour l'équipe de
france
en espérant qu'ils réussissent ce match
historique
est-ce que vous avez un pronostic à je
pense d'eux 1 pour la france la france
avec des buts but de griezmann est
peut-être un second 2ème map est allé
même chose pour vous
est-ce que vous avez un pronostic je
veux moi je pense qu'on va aller aux
prolongations et peut-être au turbo but
parce que c'est vraiment deux équipes
qui vont défendre cher leur peau voilà
et est-ce que vous avez un champ pour
encourager les bleus
on va chanter
ce jour de l'arrivée contrat de grégory
en tout cas vous l'avez vu l'ambiance et
volcanique ici et l'ambiance on va faire
que voter jusqu'au coup d'envoi du match
est bien un bon match avoue amical et
une pensée également à l'autre personne
en coulisses avec viré à la caméra pour
jacques de dixmude qui sera lui du côté
des belges ce soir et que le meilleur
gagne 1 pour eux à ce match france
belgique qui est au programme à 20
heures ce soir du football toujours un
tournoi international en corse et un
tournoi 100 % féminin qui se tenait
dimanche à montigny le bretonneux sur le
terrain des équipes françaises anglaises
mais aussi allemandes
retour sur la compétition avec michael
et demi d'euros et nicolas landry des
buts des gestes et techniques ce
dimanche 8 juillet montigny le
bretonneux a pris des allures de coupe
du monde au plus tôt de coupe d'europe
avec sept équipes féminines venues de
france d'angleterre et d'allemagne
le tournoi a créé il ya deux ans
regroupe les villes jumelées à montigny
le bretonneux ses rangs créer un lien un
lien
un lien entre les différentes villes de
jumelage de mon team moto2 c'est aussi
de créer des liens entre les filles
puisque jeudi la dernière on étale à
dayton il ya eu des fils sont et des
messages et reste en contact
c'est s'est développée aussi c'est
mettre en avant le que le foot c'est
aussi ça passe libérateur ce jour-là 70
joueuses de moins de 16 ans se sont
affrontés sur des matches à 7 contre 7
mais l'essentiel est ailleurs pour ses
footballeuses c'est bien enfin ça change
des équipes du 78 après ouais c'est
mieux d'autres langues d'autres têtes
c'est ce que viviane voilà partagent
tous la même passion le football à
travers deux pays du coup ça nous permet
aussi de voir comment les pays je pense
que c'est bien ça permet aux gens de se
retrouver de pouvoir interagir
nous apprenons des nouvelles langues on
peut parler avec des français les
allemands et apprendre à se connaître
catherine rich noria l'année prochaine
le tournoi pourrait connaître une
nouvelle édition mais cette fois ci en
allemagne c'est unis montrent un vise
l'europe cette saison l'équipe de
baseball des cougars s'est fixé comme
objectif de remporter le titre de
première division et c'est plutôt bien
parti ils sont pour l'instant classé
dans le top 4 français
un résultat qui leur permettra d'accéder
aux playoffs à partir de la mi-septembre
en attendant les cougars vont devoir a
bien géré la pause estivale
propos recueillis par nicolas landry
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué
justement de gérer la trêve estivale
on a on va reprendre 15 jours avant et
c'est de se préparer au mieux mais c'est
jamais facile quoi a pas trop le choix
l'été une période de détente une période
de vacances un moment aussi pour faire
des activités plusieurs communes de
saint quentin en yvelines ont lancé
leurs animations pour les beaux jours
comme à guyancourt on en parle avec mon
invité richard mézières bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes conseiller municipal de
guyancourt délégué au périscolaire
depuis lundi et jusqu'au 31 août
guyancourt propose beaucoup d'activités
alors notamment pour les jeunes les 11
15 ans et les 16 25 ans va détailler le
programme dans un instant déjà pourquoi
c'est important pour la ville de
s'investir pour sa jeunesse
oui il est important de continuer à
proposer des activités même pendant
l'été même pendant les vacances des
activités aux jeunes pour qui c'est qui
n'ont pas la chance de partir en
vacances puissent profiter aussi de
cette période des festivals et estivale
par nous et puis festive avec la coupe
du monde pour être dans une bonne
ambiance et puis l'avant l'impression de
partir en vacances
également les prévenus encourent propose
aussi ses 5 pour les jeunes que pour
tous les âges et tous les goûts en
courtois et dans tous les quartiers de
la ville on imagine les objectifs vous
parliez de donner l'opportunité de
s'amuser à des jeunes qui ne partent pas
forcément en vacances on imagine aussi
renforcer le lien social entre les
objectifs on a un tissu de maisons de
quartier survie en cours trois maisons
de quartier plus une maison sur une
maison 4 4 mondial 404e répartie surtout
d'eric tout le territoire qui propose un
ensemble d'activités à toute la
population aussi bien aux jeunes qu'aux
qu'aux familles avec des oeufs repas
festif en soirée ou des sorties en forêt
pour découvrir les stands ami à la fois
de la minière et avoir un peu de
fraîcheur dans cette période de ces
choses et c'est primordial de s'adresser
à tout le monde pas forcément que les
jeunes s'adresse à l'ensemble de la
population il faut s'adresser à la
recentralisation aux personnes qu'ils
soient isolés on a pour nos aînés des
services des services municipaux qui
vont à leur rencontre pour s'assurer que
tout se passe bien avec eux malgré bien
qu'ils soient isolés qu'ils ne soient
pas en difficulté vis-à-vis de la
chaleur choses comme ça on a par rapport
à nos colonnes
au centre au centre de loisirs tous les
sens de voiliers de loisirs paris sont
ouverts pendant toute la période
estivale il ya deux jours de fermeture
nous tous les efforts guillon pour toi
pour aller en centre périscolaire
oui vous parlez des maisons de quartier
pour la jeunesse la ville s'appuie sur
deux structures jeunesse que sont le
point jeunes et et le phare jeunesse le
point jeunes et le faire jeunesse donc
le point jeunes on va proposer cette
année aux journées des activités
sportives et puis des activités de
soirée un peu plus ce type bowling
barbecue dansant et puis on journée
d'activités sportives à ce sont des
stages de tennis de football au basket
ball
la culture sera pas oublier également il
y aura des stages culture loisirs la
culture ne sera pas oubliée aussi bien
dans les centres de loisirs avec des
ateliers de création tête de théâtral
vraiment on avait essayé de couvrir
quelque chose une activité à l'ensemble
de la population
sans oublier bien sûr les plus faibles
et puis ceux qui peuvent être isolés les
forcer à ne pas sortir de chez eux pour
la rencontre des autres et par exemple
on va voir une activité qu'on avait
lancé l'année dernière dans la maison de
quartier renoir s'appelle renoir plage
d'accord où on sort la maison de
quartier de bâtiment pour aller un peu
d'eau en plein air avec une installation
de
deux transats de parasols et puis des
livres qui sortent pour faciliter pour
changer un peu les habitudes de tous les
jours qu'on est aussi notre médiathèque
qui reste ouvert tout l'été
quand on parle culture les médiathèques
sont importantes donc il ya un panel est
vraiment vraiment large on peut faire de
l'activité sportive vous le disiez
culturel se rendre à la médiathèque à
diverses sorties également qui seront
proposés pour les jeunes notamment sur
les îles de loisirs la liste de loisirs
salle concerne en particulier encore une
fois les le périscolaire puisqu'on va
voir des mini-camps donc les enfants
pour aller camper dans le tipi ou sous
tente
une soirée à lille ii sur la balle
deloitte sur la base de loisirs donc
encore une fois c'est sortir un petit
peu des activités qu'on peut avoir le
reste de l'année dans ces centres de
loisirs pour avoir un aussi l'impression
d'être en vacances
et puis de avoir des choses à raconter
des choses qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de
faire raconter aux parents le soir une
question plus pratique pour participer à
ces activités faut s'inscrire au
préalable une inscription à faire au
préalable pour les centres pour le point
jeunes nous fallait au point jeunes
prendre une cotisation mais une
concession qui est valable sur toute la
vie d'accord et puis s'inscrire alors
une espéranc qu'il reste des places
parce que effectivement l'année reste
des places oui sparte part très vite
propose des choses intéressantes on
arrive à attirer du monde et donc non
non bien sûr j'ai des inscriptions
et puis après il ya des comme des repas
festifs ou glacée
il n'y a pas de places limité donc les
chaque chaque chacun vient avec son
petit rhume avec son grand pas les
pétitions aux soirées d'échangés de
convivialité toutes les informations et
pour notamment les inscriptions sont à
retrouver sur le site internet de
guyancourt qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci richard meyer d'abord
rappeler vous êtes conseiller municipal
à guyancourt délégué au périscolaire et
puis autre ville à avoir lancé son
programme d'été montigny le bretonneux
samedi dernier a débuté la 12e édition
de l'été en sable un espace estivale au
gymnase alain colas avec des animations
prévues jusqu'au 18 août reportage de
nicolas landry sur la voix d'aurélie
ronces la plage s'invite à montigny le
bretonneux l'été en sable s'installe au
gymnase alain colas toboggan aquatique
structures gonflables au château de
sable petits et grands laisse exprimer
leur esprit créatif et voilà c'est de
s'amuser aujourd'hui dans le sable sur
les structures et toboggan d'en profiter
y fait beau donc
on en profite à fond et voilà c'est
sympa à la basse et un château fort là
nous avons un tunnel c'est presque fini
et puis là nous avons fait les douves et
le château
et donc ça intéresse d'autres enfants
qui sont venus nous aider jalil sera
tout bon dos et après j'ai sauté après
somaliens dans une piscine carré avec
cette douzième édition l'été en sable
est désormais un rendez vous
incontournable à montigny le bretonneux
c'est pour permettre aussi à ceux qui ne
vont pas partir tout de suite de pouvoir
déjà se sentir en vacances
et puis il ya aussi des familles qui
pour des raisons diverses ne partent pas
forcément où voilà où nous ne partirons
pas peut-être du tout donc ça leur
permet voilà deux alors on n'a pas la
mère si on n'a pas réussi à l'emporter
encore m'écouter on ne désespère pas
près de 24 mille personnes sont
attendues durant l'été en sable une
animation prévue jusqu'au 18 août
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité
retrouvez nous sur notre site internet
et notre application mobile tv 78 très
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]